Tonight
on Follow the Money, oil at 100 bucks a
barrel as Libya burns. Will your furnace
keep burning too?
Deadly battles in the street of Libya as
Gaddafi clings to power. Americans
fleeing the country. And some reports
say Gaddafi has ordered troops to
sabotage his own oil fields. The
message, it's either me or chaos. As a
result, oil surging. Joining me now is
Robert Spencer, director of Jihad Watch.
Robert, what's the endgame here? Uh, if
Gaddafi does torch the oil fields, by
the way, would he do something like
that? Oh, sure he would. I mean, this is
a guy who has been crazy for years. you
know, he's been uh it's just been
revealed that he is the one who ordered
the Locker B be bombing back uh how long
ago was it in the '8s. And uh so the uh
idea that he would not do something like
this there this there is never a man
who's behaved with restraint or with any
calculation of uh the general welfare.
Yeah, do me a favor. Uh pull up that
screen. Let me show you what what
exactly what we're talking about. The
oil fields um in Libya. Here it is.
here. They're very, very, very sensitive
area right through here. These are oil
pipelines and oil platforms and oil
drilling rigs that are that are bringing
about 1.7 million barrels of oil out of
the ground every day. And why does that
matter? Here's Egypt. You see what's
going on in Egypt. You see Libya. You we
already heard about Algeria over up
here. Um, Bahrain is going crazy. And
here is the big one right over here. You
guys, Saudi Arabia is here and Iran is
here. Be very careful of that area. Is
that is that am I am I crazy? Uh,
Robert, when I say $200 a barrel, $300 a
barrel if the region were to spread, if
it were to spread to Saudi Arabia,
you're not crazy at all, Eric. That's a
very real possibility, especially if it
spreads to Saudi Arabia. And look, it
already is. I mean, the king just today
announced that he's giving a $37 billion
package of aid to his own citizens,
which is obviously an attempt to try to
keep the lid on things there and to make
sure that all this unrest doesn't spread
to the kingdom. Oh, where is why do we
not hear from President Obama? I
understand um Secretary of State Clinton
came out earlier today and and made a
bit of a statement, but where's Obama on
this? Why why is it not in his best
interest to get out there and get in
front of this? Well, for one thing,
because he's been hopelessly on the
wrong side all the way from the
beginning. remember that back in June
2009, as you mentioned, his speech in
Cairo, which was supposed to be this
incredible new overture to the Islamic
world that was going to end all this
conflict, he made sure specifically to
invite members of the Muslim
Brotherhood, which was at that time and
still is an illegal organization in
Egypt, to attend his speech. And so he
has always shown not only in that
instance but also when he had a member
of the the president of the Islamic
Society of North America which is a
Muslim Brotherhood linked organization
give one of the prayers at his
inauguration and when he sent Valerie
Jared one of his top adviserss to be the
keynote speaker at the Islamic Society
of North America's annual convention.
He's always shown a warmly positive
attitude toward the very groups that are
most dangerous and most enimical to
American interests in the Middle East
right now. Stay with us. He's reaping
what he swed. Stay with us, please.
Joining me on tonight's all-star panel.
On the left, Fox News contributor Mr.
Juan Williams. And on the right, former
New York Senator Mr. Al Demano. Fox News
contributor Monica Crowley and Fox News
medical contributor Dr. Keith Abau, the
co-author of the seven seven wonders
that will change your life. Guys, um,
Juan, I'm going to start with you. I was
very hard on the president on the in the
opening. You disagree with me? Strongly.
Uh, I just think that it's, you know,
you want to blow off some steam, but the
fact is President Bush, President Obama,
these guys don't know what to do right
now, Eric. And it's easy to say, send in
the military. You want us to have
another war? I I thought you want to
blow up the oil. What I said was what I
said was pick up the phone and call King
Abdul of Saudi Arabia and say by the way
you see the spreading violence you don't
oil how long how long how long have we
been backing autocrats and monarchs and
what has it brought us terrorism we
don't want to back those people anymore
we want democracy in the Middle East
terrorism terrorism um what are we
talking about Egyptian terror I've heard
of Egyptian terrorists you forget who
attacked us on 911 no those were Saudis
and Egyptians oh we haven't gone in
there yet we haven't said hey we'll take
care of this we'll clean this up Monica
Well, look, my first memory of Mar
Gaddafi was 1986. And the reason he was
on television in 1986 is because he
ordered the bombing of a West Berlin
disco that was frequented by American
servicemen. Hundreds of our servicemen
were wiped out along with countless
others. You know what President Reagan
did at the time? He ordered the bombing
of Tripoli and Benghazi. And he sent a
very strong signal to Omar Gaddafi that
that he was not going to play, that the
United States was not going to play.
Here we've got a situation where this
regime is teetering on the brink. This
is a morally clear example crying out
for presidential leadership. Okay, it's
not like Egypt where we've had a
longstanding steadfast ally in Hosni
Mubarak that President Obama threw under
the bus. This guy Omar Kaddafi is a
clear enemy of the United States and a
terrorist both in word and deed. Guys,
do me a favor. Pull up the uh pin at the
pump screen. Here's what I I'm going to
send it over to the senator and and Dr.
Keith in a second, but take a look at
this. When Mr. Obama was was sworn in
January 20th, 2009, there it is, guys. A
$183 a gallon, Senator, $183 for regular
national average. A year ago, $2.61 a
gallon. Today, $3.19. Now, why does that
matter? Because every dollar on the
pump, every dollar on the pump cost
Americans $138 billion out of their
pocket. Sir, you're going to go to $5.
There's no doubt. short term, it will
hit $200. And I say short term, I don't
think this is going to be uh something
that's with us uh long term. Uh but
certainly we should let Saudi Arabia
know uh that we're going to be
supportive. It's in our interest. the
business about democracy. I always let
Bush overplayed it because if you had
democracy, true democracy, one man, one
vote or one person, one vote, um, every
one of those countries uh would be going
into a fundamentalist
uh uh kind of regime. Understand it. Um,
even in Saudi Arabia, there are 12 and a
half million people, 2 and a half
million Saudis. The rest were
expatriots. They've never allowed them
to become Saudi citizens. And so you sew
the seeds and you reap what's happening
there. They are hated, but they they've
got great power because of their police,
because of their money, etc. We're on a
tinder box. There's no doubt. Understand
it. That region is changing and probably
in the fullness of time, no matter what
we do or no matter what we try to do,
and I'm not saying we should be absent,
um you will have theocracies throughout
that region, very much like Iran. Go
ahead. Look, maybe call me a purist
rather than somebody of practical
intent, but the bottom line is you have
to stand with principle. True. And we
are one man, one vote. That's what we
stand for. If we have to suffer in the
meantime, if those countries need to uh
descend into darkness for a period of
time, so be it. In order to then shine
in in the light. Bottom line is that the
president should be the leader here
saying a true democracy that emerges in
any of these countries, I'm with you.
anything else, I'll oppose you. Uh, and
as to Gaddafi, we're not with you
because that's not a democracy, and we
stand with whoever should replace him as
long as it's a real and true democracy.
Why not? Why not be principal? Allow me
to bring it to Mr. Spencer. What What
message are we telling the world when we
can't find a president when Algeria
burns, when Tunisia burns, when Egypt
burns, and now when Libya is burning?
Well, the message we're certainly
sending to all those countries is that
the United States has advocated its
position as the world leader and that
they have to go elsewhere to find
direction. And where they're going is
exactly what Senator Damato said.
They're going to the Islamic
supremacists. Those states, if they have
true democracy, they're going to be
Islamic states and they're going to be
far more hostile to the United States
than anything we've seen before in that
region. One, we haven't seen any
evidence that the Brotherhood, for
example, is taking over in Egypt. we
understand and okay not yet. So you I
mean don't don't be out there, you know,
fearmongering. And the second thing to
say is that the big threat in this
region is Iran. They're having their own
internal troubles, but that's the big
threat. If you can get a situation
where, for example, you know, the Shia
start to identify with the Iranians in a
place like Libya or elsewhere, you know,
then you one, I think it's critical, I I
think it's critical, hang on, Robert.
Hi, Robert, by the way. Um, Juan, I
think it's critical that we deal in
reality here. And the reality is that in
the Muslim world, there are the vast
majority of Muslims are devout enough
there that if they are given the chance
to exercise a vote, they will choose an
Islamic regime of some form. The other
thing to keep in mind is that in Egypt,
even though they're not in the forefront
of this, what the Muslim Brotherhood
does very effectively is lay back and
orchestrate under the radar. Two weeks
before the initial demonstrations in
Egypt, guess who was orchestrating the
very first Senator, last word. We're
going to have to leave it very shortly.
Last word to you, sir. Let me tell you,
this is a tinder box. We haven't even
touched Somalia. Um, and by the way, we
should become involved there. You can
take care of those pirates. The Somalian
government can't do it alone. Um, if you
really want to take on al-Qaeda and beat
them, that's a place you can do it. It's
a country of 4 million people. Um, the
new prime minister is an American
citizen from Buffalo who brought over
eight new ministers and who's trying
desperately and we need, you know what
our aid there is? $5 million a year.
There is where you can win. There is
where if we got the countries of the
world to police the seas together
instead of the French watching the
French ships, the Italian watching the
Italians, all of them together, you
could make a difference. Last, real
quick, last word for me. Juan, I got to
challenge you on this. The president,
this is a moment for real leadership,
and I I don't know why you're giving him
a pass on this. Ronald Reagan defined uh
the the evil empire, and things started
to change during the Cold War. Why can't
the president voice real leadership
here? Where is he? Why won't he ends
with a
last word? I don't want We have a lot
more time with this, sir. We're going to
have to thank Robert Senator Senator
Alan.